um you guys know i'm really into what
words mean i actually haven't even
looked this up i'm just like it's weird
and strange
you go look it up and find what the what
the root word is okay
heuristic heuristics um what does this
mean
well the best way i can say it is it's a
rule of thumb
it's a rule of thumb what's a rule of
thumb when i say
oh here's something here's some advice
but it's just a rule of thumb what does
that mean
yeah that's right it's it's usually true
i mean there are exceptions
but this will get you through most of
the way okay so example
a rule of thumb uh i was just talking
about what rose to take on a journey
right so that's a decision
a rule of thumb is that in peak hour
which one is slower a main road or a
back street
a main road is generally true even
though the speed limit is faster on the
main road
if it's peak hour generally there'll be
more cars on there okay
but it's not always true can someone
think of an exception to that
if there's if there's roadworks on the
back streets or if there's like an
accident or something like that now both
of those are exceptional
they're not they sort of uh contradict
the rule of thumb because they don't
usually
they're not usually true okay but still
it's not like a guarantee
okay it's not this is always going to
happen okay
so uh let me try and give you a more um
computery sort of
situation okay let's have a look at i'm
going to open this up actually
hold on i'm going to mute this first so
you don't see what i'm logging into
or how long you
oh password
you need counting lessons oh no
oh maybe that's mr trump
here is my example of heuristics now
what are we looking at
okay this is my spam folder here's my
spam folder okay
um i didn't say it was spam i said this
is my spam folder
okay now spam and identifying it
is a decision support problem okay
because what's the decision
what's the decision that has to be made
is this mail legit
is it from a legit person is it
intended for you you know really okay
all of those questions
uh have to be answered by gmail right so
there's a decision support system
devoted to that okay now what kind of
heuristics does it use what kind of
rules of thumbs does it employ
well let's have a look for instance
let's have a look at this top one here
okay now without any sophisticated
algorithms or knowledge you guys all
right now are employing a heuristic that
tells you
that spam right what are you what are
you using what are you using what's
what's going on
okay number one you're like mary beth
that's not what is that like where do
you have no surname like what are you
the artist formerly known as mary beth
or something um
so that's kind of weird what else in the
subject there's some suspicious stuff
what's up
that there's
there's a dollar sign instead of an s
and there's a
an exclamation mark instead of an o like
that doesn't even look remotely similar
okay now
um that's you know some people could
send emails like that
i mean if you wanted to but this is
suspicious right so what's my rule of
thumb
okay number one i don't know anyone
named mary beth number two even if i did
it would not be spelled that way
number three even if it was spelled that
way they'd probably have a surname
number four
uh what's up with this messed up wordy
okay so these are all of my
rules of thumb which i employ which by
the way
might be or wrong okay uh there might be
someone i don't know
who really does spell their name this
way who really has no surname
and just is fond of you know using
symbols
in their language and that's what they
she really wants me to know about
the best medicine healthcare products
that are online okay this could be legit
now but
probably generally this is spam
okay but you can see heuristics
sometimes get it wrong
don't they so let's see here um
see now i think i know that guy and
maybe you
do um this is real mail
right but it's been sent to spam okay
why would it be sent to spam
what kind of heuristics do you think
would be a play that sent this to spam
okay number one i may have actually
tagged a spam
but in terms of huge things i'm thinking
about what happens automatically like
what's happening without my intervention
why do you think this might have gone to
spam yeah
okay good number one right when we send
emails to each other usually we're like
hey what's up have you done the
assignment or something like that right
okay or or hey
here are my answers for the starbucks
successful so that okay we don't
generally say
hey hey park check out this awesome link
you know that that's suspicious
okay and then you click okay right now
there are other things that are
suspicious about this as well for
instance have a look at this i don't
know if you pay much attention to this
okay
where did this email come from um well
two things to notice okay uh number one
look at that what is that okay
can someone tell me what is that that's
that's something real
why is that so full of you know
gibberish
now this address uh both of these
addresses have been
automatically generated by a computer
okay there wasn't like mark zuckerberg's
like i think this is a great email
just to have it our computer made those
up okay
and uh it's made them up and they're
different see how they're not the same
okay and that's sus right the from and
the reply to are not the same that's
really weird okay so heuristically
right gmail has said yeah this is
probably um
yeah and you can see it even says be
careful with this message
here's an additional thing our systems
couldn't verify that this message was
really sent by
who it says it's coming from okay
so it's a bit like if i get a text from
you okay oh sorry start again if i get a
text an anonymous number
and it's signed off as you right it's
like
well i can't really know if it was you
because it wasn't the number i had for
you before
okay so this is kind of suspicious okay
and in this case
probably most of us think actually it's
not spam right so i should i should mark
it as such
okay but you can see how the use of a
heuristic a general
rule of thumb these things do generally
mean
indicate span right that's what sent
this to the spam folder
okay so that's what a heuristic
is now you often hear about this used in
like antivirus software
okay why do you think antivirus software
will be really big on
heuristics and not so much
on either of these approaches up here
there are lots of viruses that's true
but when i'm satisfied there might be
lots of different solutions
why might this be particularly relevant
yeah that's right number one they're
going to be trying to uh
masquerade as something else okay number
two they're always changing
and it's not like the optimization
problem it's a completely different kind
of problem can you see that they're
trying to make a decision about
it's not like oh yes i have a million
different things and i just have to go
through all of them one by one
and see which one's the best okay this
is answering
a completely different question right
it's not about which one's the best
it's about whether or not this is spam
or not okay so you see
there's decisions and there's decisions
they're all different in terms of what
you actually have to choose
so that's why you've got different
strategies okay